foreign
[Music]
the Lord of the Rings trilogy by Peter
Jackson is to this day one of the
biggest film franchises known across
generations and still enjoyed by many
Amazon also acknowledged this a few
years ago when it secured the rights for
its own series set in the second age of
Middle Earth however the series was not
as successful with fans as those in
charge had hoped and in terms of
popularity in particular it falls short
of the movie trilogy from the 2000s by a
long way now as has been reported by
variety there are big plans from Warner
Brothers for new feature films based on
the Lord of the Rings Universe at the
time the movie studio was responsible
for the production of both the Lord of
the Rings and The Hobbit trilogy during
the presentation of Warner's quarterly
figures there was the surprising news
that the company will work together with
the embracer group on new movies in the
future Last Summer the embracer group
secured Middle Earth Enterprises mean
complete film and Merchandising rights
for the franchise they are now
cooperating with Warner Brothers in a
multi-year deal by the way there should
be no conflicts in terms of story with
the ongoing Amazon series since it is
set in the second age and according to
reports the upcoming films will again
focus on the third age as announced by
the new heads of the Warner Brothers
film group Michael Deluca and Pamela
Abdi there are still many stories to be
explored in the gigantic Universe of The
Lord of the Rings Creator J.R.R Tolkien
and they would like to immerse
themselves deeper into the world of
Middle Earth along with the fans we are
definitely excited and look forward to
more news from the upcoming the Lord of
the Rings series and movies however it
will certainly take a few more years
until the first movie releases
foreign
[Music]